hallo klickzoom
hallo Felix philiip Christian Uwe
Silvester und Ludwig ich bin Nick von
schg TV und meine Frage wäre wie habt
ihr es eigentlich geschafft groß
rauszukommen habt ihr Demo CDs zu
plattenfilm geschickt oder wurdet ihr
entdeckt lasst es mich bitte
wissen t die Frage ist warum möchtest du
das Wissen bist du selber Musiker
möchtest du auch groß rauskommen
vielleicht bist du ja schon groß
rausgekommen m ich glaube so groß
rausgekommen sind wir noch gar nicht
deshalb
wir haben zwar schon mal einen Hit
gehabt aber wir sind auch nicht
übermäßig Reich was wir auf jeden Fall
gemacht haben uns gibt es sehr sehr
lange wir haben uns
wir haben ganz ganz viele Demo CDs
verschickt ja und
haben nie auf eine CD Antwort bekommen
und haben dann letztlich etwas gemacht
was wir als Band sehr
sehr was sehr sehr heiß diskutiert war
wir haben an eine Musikwettbewerb
teilgenommen und in diesem
Musikwettbewerb saß unser Manager und
der hat uns dann sozusagen freut und hat
uns dann zu einem Label gebracht und so
ging dann alles rasend schnell nach 10
Jahren bendgeschichte haben wir dann
eine Plattenfirma gefunden und so ging
das dann
los